why
so as we get into Avengers disassembled
what we're going to find is a story
taking place on two fronts but before we
actually get into this video what I
would suggest is that if you haven't
already go back and watch my video about
Scarlet Witch and the reason why is
because what this will do is help us
understand how we got to this place how
we got to this point where by the
Scarlet Witch had effectively waged war
against the Avengers but we're also
going to I guess learn and understand
what it is that led to the psychotic
breakdown of the Scarlet Witch how it
was that she began to become mentally
unstable to the point where the entire
Avengers disassembled story happened now
with the Avengers disassembled story
proper what we're going to find is again
we're going to have this story on two
fronts The Avengers are actually going
to disassemble due to the actions of
Iron Man but the rest of the events the
conflicts that the Avengers get into and
so on this will actually be a lead-up
more or less to the House of M storyline
this will show us just how far gone The
Scarlet Witch is and what it is it took
place that led up to the formation of
the House of M alternate universe and
then the restoration and the following
decimation storyline so what we see is
we start this Avengers disassembled
event is that we pick up with with Clint
Barton is Hawkeye with Scott Lang
she-hulk and various other people who
were just having this sort of are in our
time who are just having this general
conversation amongst one another about
various things there really isn't
anything in terms of extreme topical
items here they're more or less just
talking about various women or at least
the men are talking about various women
and and so on and so forth but again
before this conversation gets too far
before they actually get too deep into
it we see that the security system
alerts the current Avengers that there
is some kind of a security breach on the
grounds that it's actually in the back
cord and then it's a level red security
threat which is the second highest alert
that the Avengers have and so what Janet
Van Dyne does as she tells the security
system to show them this breach to show
them this security violation and so what
we learn is that the person who has
breached the security walls of reach the
barricade of the Avengers mansion is a
hero or a person by the name of Joe
of Hearts now Jack of Hearts was a
former Avenger who had died in Avengers
issue number 491 and he has the ability
to channel a type of energy called zero
energy but the problem with this is that
his body effectively wasn't able to
control these energies once it got to a
certain point and so what ended up
happening here is rather than relegating
himself to a life whereby he had to keep
himself contained in order to keep other
people safe he chose to simply just
commit suicide in space and Scott Lang
was the last person to see him and this
is why Scott Lang we I guess reacts this
way this is why he is so struck by this
now initially the other Avengers here
don't believe this is Jack of Hearts
they're actually surprised to see this
because at this point again it's common
knowledge the Jack of Hearts had been
killed and so what she hope does is she
asked the computer to identify this
person to confirm whether or not this is
Jack of Hearts and the computer does the
computer says this this identity is
confirmed than it is Jack of Hearts but
this version of Jack is a zombified
version it's not his normal self that so
again the Avengers are trying to figure
out what's going on but before they get
too far Scott Lang immediately shrinks
down into his a to a smaller Ant Man
form then goes out to meet Jack now when
he does he of course goes back into his
regular size and he confronts Jack he
tries to identify with Jack he tells him
that it's Scott and so on and so forth
and what he does here is try to find
some way to penetrate the supposed
catatonic state with a zombie v Azam
defied form of Jack of Hearts but Jack
doesn't appear to be reacting to to
Scott Lang at all he doesn't appear to
be responding to what it is that he's
saying but then suddenly and without
warning Jack of Hearts turns and looks
at Scott Lang and says I'm sorry and
then immediately explodes he actually
detonates and so the result is that in
the ensuing in the ensuing explosion and
the pandemonium that it turns out that
Scott Lang had been killed
now this isn't immediately recognized by
the by the Avengers that are current in
fact we see that Jarvis and she-hulk
among others are trying to move
themselves away from the debris trying
to get out from under all the rubble and
they start looking around Hawkeye is
told to take point to examine the area
and to make sure there's nobody else
present but once the Avengers begin
looking around for a Scott Lang since he
hasn't identified himself as being there
that's when they come upon the real is a
that Scott Lang died in the explosion
that he died in the conflict and so from
here we switched to Tony Stark now this
is when we actually get the basis behind
why the Avengers are disassembled this
is going to be a reaction to something
that Tony Stark has done here and what
he's doing is he's speaking to the
United Nations on behalf of the federal
government but also on behalf of himself
of course as we know at this point in
time Tony Stark is the secretary of
defense for the United States but again
he's also a military industrialist but
before he actually gets into a
discussion about what it is that he is
basically addressing addressing the UN
for he begins to sort of freak out a
little bit he begins to stutter he
begins to sputter and then apparently he
begins to display the effects of
alcoholism to make it seem as though
he's drunk and what he does is he
initially addresses the ambassador of
Latveria and begins mocking him begins
referring to him as esteemed in a
sarcastic tone now this is very
indicative of Tony Stark during the
demon in a bottle storyline during the
storyline where Marvel had heavily
focused on his alcoholism and the way
that he acted when he was drunk and for
all those present including yellow
jacket in T'Challa it seems as though
Tony Stark is in fact under entire I
guess he is intoxicated and so what Hank
Pym does is he tells Tony Stark to stop
he tells him to step down but Tony Stark
says what and he says that maybe he's
the juror I'm sorry that he's not the
jerk here but maybe the ambassador of
Liberia is the jerk here that he's
simply just saying what everybody else
is thinking here and so what did chala
does is he steps up as the ambassador
for Wakanda and tells Tony Stark to stop
the second person to tell Tony he needs
to quit but then we see Tony use one of
his I guess energy projectors from his
hand and pointed at the ambassador of
Latveria indicating that perhaps he's
going to kill him and so again we see
that through the combined efforts of
Scarlet Witch and Hank Pym and T'Challa
they're able to talk Tony Stark down and
so what Tony Stark does is he goes away
he simply walks away but not before
making a reference to Hank him about
supposedly having beated his wife now
from here we switch to one of the
observation decks where Tony Stark is
watching Hank Pym apologize to the
United Nations for Tony Stark's actions
and Hardy Stark feels were very
regretful here he's very angry at the
that he was acting but more so than that
what he tells the Scarlet Witch is that
he knows the feeling of being drunk he
knows how it is when he is drunk and
initially Scarlet Witch thinks that
maybe he's been drinking that maybe he
had relapsed after being sober for so
long but Tony Stark says no he says that
he hasn't had anything to drink at all
today but he hasn't had any kind of
alcohol and he doesn't know why it is
that he's acting this way
before he's able to expand further on
this we see that he gets an alert from
Avengers mansion a white coat alert
which is the highest level of priority
the Avengers can send out as a distress
call and so what we do is we switch back
to the Avengers mansion and the
aftermath of the explosion of a Jack of
Hearts that had killed a Scott Lang and
what we see The Avengers doing it's
saying that there's perhaps some kind of
radiation here that people need to be
careful they can't do get too close so
the place is going to be a crime scene
and that shield will arrive momentarily
we also see that the Captain America is
talking to Jarvis he's trying to
understand what had happened here and in
fact he goes as far as to ask Travis
what it is that had taken place but
Jarvis says that he doesn't really know
here he really can't give Tony or give a
Captain America a lot of specifics all
he really knows is that at some point
along the line there was an alert that
would then inform them of a security
breach and then there was a sudden
explosion and so what we see is that
Captain America's attention is drawn
away from Jarvis when he realizes there
was a ship coming in full speed at
Avengers mansion and the ship is not
coming to a stop it's not slowing down
but once he actually sees who's inside
of the cockpit he realizes that it's the
vision and so the vision ship crashes
into Avengers mansion adding again to
the existing chaos and so what happens
here is we switch to the vision as he as
I guess as they exit the ship as he
steps out and begins addressing the
Avengers directly now what the vision
does here is effectively try to tell the
Avengers what's going on he tries to
explain to them what's going on but it
seems that for whatever reason he's not
capable of doing so what he tells them
is that he's ahe's shown up to bid them
tidings in this dark hour when he says
that he's no longer in control of his
body and the Avengers are no longer in
control of the group or the world or
even themselves and so he says that it's
important that they understand that
they've although they're all about to be
judged that they're all about to be
punished because they have an effect as
a group totally failed now this is
uncharacteristic of the vision because
the vision is talking about the actions
of the Avengers but he's not giving any
context and so it seems as though maybe
he's being forced to say this or he's
being coerced to say this and if that
Captain America goes as far as to notice
this he asked the vision what it is it's
happened here he asked the vision to
tell them what it is it's going on but
the vision says that while initially
this will seem somehow seem like some
kind of a betrayal but it's not him who
has brought this plague of destruction
upon the Avengers and that he doesn't
know how to tell them who it is but that
he's feeling an overwhelming amount of
guilt and so what happens is his body
appears to be breaking down perhaps
dissolving or breaking down on its maybe
cellular level or it passes for cells
within the body of the vision but what
he does is he began spitting out these
metal spheres about five in total and of
course each of them are about the size
of a maybe an orange or a little bit
larger and Captain America initially
appears to either know what's going on
or be suspicious of what's going on and
so what he does is tell the Avengers to
fall back he tells them to get out of
there and what happens is that each of
these spheres begins to grow take on
some kind of a form and when they reach
their I guess their final state each of
them are in the form of Ultron
indicating that perhaps Ultron is now
invading the Avengers mansion and so
what Captain America does using his
shield to protect the rest of the
Avengers is he again tells them to fall
back but Janet Van Dyne asks him where
are they supposed to go then this is a
very good question and the reason why is
because if the Avengers were to leave if
they were to run away and regroup then
they would leave the city of New York
virtually defenseless against the
presumed onslaught of these Ultron
robots and so the only choice they
really have right now is to do what they
can to bring this destruction to an end
and so this is what we see the avengers
doing they begin engaging the Ultron
robots and doing what they can to try to
defeat these Ultron robots we of course
see that Hawkeye shoots several levels
arrows into the mouths of these Ultron
robots but what it appears here where
the VESA the very least seems to us is
that these Ultron robots are I guess
maybe duplicates of Ultron when he had
his adamantium armor indicating to us
that this Ultron robot is
is not not going to be I guess very
easily destroyed by the Avengers and
indeed once the the arrows explode the
Ultron robots are virtually unharmed and
so again they continue their assault
they continue their attack on the
Avengers but what we also begin to
notice here is that she-hulk begins to
display a very extreme attitude she
begins to display a very bizarre kind of
attitude
now this isn't initially unnoticed by
the Avengers they're too focused on the
Ultron robots and of course we see a Jan
van dawn asking the question are all
these things connected is the explosion
of Jack of Hearts killing Scott Lang
connected to these Ultron robots being
spawned by the vision and the visions
ominous words but again no one really
knows what's going on and in fact a
falcon goes as far as to say that he has
no real idea what's taking place and so
we again see that as she-hulk begins to
go into this bruiser cursed 8 she begins
to freak out then go more and more
insane and so what happens here is that
as the Ultron robots are being attacked
as they're being fought by the Avengers
Captain America comes upon a very
important weakness in the Ultron robots
and that is there's no adamantium at
their necks they're actually a very
vulnerable in this place and so after
beheading one of the Ultron robots
cutting off at the neck he tells the
other Avengers the same thing he tells
them to go for the neck and so we see
she hooked hearing off the heads of one
of the Ultron robots as well as Falcon
decapitating one of them and this is
when we see she hoped begin to take a
turn this is when we see this berserker
rage that she's going through start to
manifest itself more so than before and
the Avengers begin to realize that while
the Ultron threat is now gone that a new
threat in the form of she-hulk has
started to emerge and indeed she hope
begins to lash out she begins to freak
out
she asks of course whether or not this
is something that they've deserved
whether or not this is something that
they've earned but what she also wants
to know is why all this is happening in
the first place then from here Captain
America tries to reason with her Captain
America tries to tell her that she needs
to stop but she turns and tells Captain
America there's no reason for her to and
ultra I'm sorry that vision is not even
human that vision is just a robot it's
just a thing and that it had tried to
kill them so in the end it doesn't
matter what she does but again Kat
America tries to tell her to stop and
Hawkeye tries to tell her to calm down
and so what happens here is that again
she-hulk freaks out when she tears up
the vision and half and the rest of the
Avengers see this and I think they
realize here that there's really nothing
they can do that she is basically beyond
hope and so what happens here is Jan van
dyne tries to tell she-hulk as she needs
to stop as she needs to calm down the
she's in control of herself that unlike
Bruce Banner and the Incredible Hulk
she doesn't lose control when she
becomes the Incredible Hulk but again
she hoped health Janet Van Dyne to shut
up and she smacks her presumably
knocking her unconscious and so what she
does is she goes on the offense against
Captain America now Captain America is
able to use his shield who initially
protect himself but due to the
reverberation of the shield the fact
that it absorbs sound this reverberation
in turn impacts Captain America and it
seems to knock him unconscious now what
she helped us from here is she picks up
one of the larger vehicles and goes to
smash Captain America but as she does it
Captain America begins to wake up
indicating that this may very well be
the final moments of Captain America's
life that Captain America could very
well be killed here from here we
switched to a conversation that's
apparently taking place between a couple
individuals the first individual asks
the question is this over is all this
said and done but the second individual
says no the first individual asks again
is there more is something more coming
beyond this and the second individual
says there's going to be a lot more and
so what the second individuals continues
to say here is that there are many of
these Avengers that they all have a lot
to answer for now one of the individuals
says that we should kill them and be
done with it that they should just call
it quits and kill all the Avengers but
the first person goes back and says that
this wouldn't prove anything that it
would be pointless to do so and so what
they say is that again this is not over
that there's a lot more coming where
this came from
with that being said we're going to go
ahead and bring this video to an end I
hope you guys enjoyed it if you did let
me know and I will catch you guys later
peace